[Music]
as a part of our black history month
coverage cbs this morning is taking a
look at the challenges black americans
face
when trying to find a job or climb the
corporate ladder
research from 2019 found black americans
only made up
3.2 percent of senior leadership roles
at large companies
and according to a new linkedin survey
81 percent of black professionals say
seeing other black people in positions
of leadership
would make their workplace feel more
inclusive we spoke with zachary a
consultant and shanique a marriage and
family therapist
about what they say their experiences
have been with racial inequity at work
it seems like it's a little bit
difficult for people to either remember
my name or pronounce it correctly or
remember to pronounce it correctly
and so they would often ask for well
what's your middle name
um what's your you know do you have a
nickname which definitely makes me feel
ashamed of my name at times
because it seems like i'm not good
enough or i'm
stereotyped as a young black man in
corporate america folks have said all
types of things about me i've been told
i'm
too arrogant too aggressive sometimes
not aggressive enough
too proactive not proactive enough
looking for a job
in the corporate world i had two resumes
both resumes were the same except one
resume had shanique on there the other
resume had charlie
if i put about 10 resumes out
about seven came back for charlie
seven phone calls to offer a job or
offer an interview came back for charlie
about two came back for shanique i was
gunning for a promotion
and i was doing my thing now look i'm
killing it right like i'm actually
doing all types of work working in and
outside of my
business unit i am doing above and
beyond
i find out i got a white counterpart he
quits
close to the top of the year and then he
comes back
right before the promotion decisions are
determined and that guy
got promoted with me so equal outcomes
but
effort was not equal but what i also
realized is
i'm not the only person out there
experiencing this why create a living
corporate a digital media network
that centers and amplifies black and
brown folks at work gestures are cool
days off are cool but the reality is if
you're not letting
black and brown folks make actual
decisions that can impact
systemic change you're not doing
anything
linkedin career expert andrew mccaskill
joins us now with more on race and
and equity uh in the workplace it's all
part of our partnership with linkedin
andrew good morning to you
i want to get to the resume issue
because it's really fascinating and
disturbing
but i want to start with your reporting
so you also spoke with black
professionals about what they face in
the workplace
what'd you learn and what needs to
change
a lot needs to change what we learned
was that black professionals
overwhelmingly
saw that responded that things that were
barriers to their advancement were
not seeing people who look like them at
top in senior leadership
not having access to mentorship and
sponsorship
not feeling a sense of belonging in the
workplace and
finally just feeling like that there was
no path for them
for advancement all of those things
culminate to
to black professionals feeling like that
there's more opportunity outside of the
workforce and
working for themselves then working for
companies and corporations
so let's talk about this resume issue we
heard uh shanique say that when she
sends out her resume with the name
charlie on top of it charlie wright she
gets seven callbacks if she sends out
the same
resume with shanique right on it she
only gets two and that actually matches
up with your findings and with other
people's research
what the heck is going on there what
happens is
oftentimes unconscious bias is is in
place sometimes just actual biases in
place
but people with equal qualifications and
skills don't always get equal outcomes
and the unfortunate fact is that a lot
of professionals are starting to say
feel like that they have to whiten their
resume or remove
racial descriptors from their resumes i
went to a historically black college i
went to morehouse college i can't
imagine having to
thinking i have to take that off my
resume but the onus is on
the corporations to put things in place
to
make sure that racial discrimination for
in their
hiring process doesn't creep in and you
have to be intentional about it
it doesn't just happen organically yeah
so let's let's talk about the intentions
because i love
zachary and i love shanique i thought
they raised really great points
so what should employers do to put that
in place and be intentional give us two
top things they could do
today today is they can do blind
recruitment where
they look in at the in the hiring
process and start to just only look at
qualifications and skills
the other thing that they can do is that
they have to be
hold themselves accountable they need to
start to measure and think about
the number of people from
underrepresented groups who are applying
for roles and opportunities
and then juxtapose that to the number of
folks who actually get call backs
and get hired in the end this is not the
responsibility of the job seeker
it requires extra effort for inclusion
and that has to be something that
everybody at the corporation
is willing to to go along with it
requires extra effort
you know they also talk about fear of
retaliation uh
black people in the workplace when they
speak up about it
so you know you're looked at as
complaining or
causing trouble what other obstacles do
they face
and how to navigate that
there there's so many other obstacles
that they face but i think gail that
one in four black respondents said that
they fear retaliation
and so that means that we have to have
allies in this process
is that if you are a leader you should
be talking about inclusion
because that sets the tone for culture
people are not
leaving they're just not leaving their
jobs they're leaving toxic cultures
and they're leaving the the they're not
wanting to have to deal with things like
microaggressions at work or feeling like
there's hopelessness at work so one
thing that people can do is if you're a
leader
talk about this have the hard
conversations
it shouldn't just be black people and
people of color or people who are other
talking about inequities at work because
one in four black folks said that they
felt like
that they would receive retaliation when
they talk about inequities so we need
our non-black counterparts to jump in
and talk about it too
yeah it may be a hard conversation but
it's a necessary conversation drew
mccaskill good to see you thank you so
much for joining us today